حسنًا ، من المؤكد أن الأمر أصبح أكثر هدوءًا
هنا في العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف ،
كما تعلم ، لدينا صفارات الإنذار من الغارات الجوية
عدة مرات خلال اليوم ، ولكن
بشكل عام ، من المؤكد أنها أقل
بكثير مما رأيناه في
الأسبوع الماضي وحتى  في اليومين الماضيين
والأوكرانيين يقولون بشكل أساسي
أن الروس يغادرون
المناطق المحيطة بكييف يتراجعون عن
الروس بالطبع يزعمون أن هذا كان
دائمًا جزءًا من خطتهم
وأنهم يتراجعون الآن
عما نراه الآن  نظرًا لأن الروس
يرحلون ، فهم بالتأكيد
قد تكبدوا بعض الخسائر الجسيمة ، كما تعلمون ،
كنت في بعض هذه المناطق
حول كييف ورأينا الكثير من
جثث الدبابات دمرت المركبات المدرعة
ثم أيضًا المواقع التي
تخلى عنها الروس مثل  لقد انتقلوا
من هنا ، والشيء الآخر
للأسف الذي اكتشفناه أيضًا هو
أنه لا يزال هناك الكثير من
الجثث التي لم يتم استردادها بعد في
الواقع ، كان هناك بعض مقاطع الفيديو التي ظهرت
من منطقة تسمى bucha
تقع إلى الشمال الغربي من كييف حيث
يبدو أن الشوارع مليئة
بالجثث ، يقول الأوكرانيون الآن إنهم
سيحاولون جلب
بعضهم بعيدًا وتنظيف تلك المنطقة بأكملها
حتى الأوكرانيين  من
جانبهم يقولون إن هذه
ليست النهاية بالتأكيد ، ويقولون إنهم يعتقدون أن
القوات الروسية تعرضت للضرب أثناء
محاولتهم غزو العاصمة كييف وهم يحاولون الآن بشكل
أساسي إعادة تجميع صفوفهم في الواقع
يقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون إنهم يعتقدون
أن الهجمات ستشتد خاصة
في  جنوب شرق البلاد ، وهو
بالتأكيد شيء يستعدون
له
بشكل عام ، ما الذي يجب أن نقرأه في
معلومات المخابرات الأمريكية التي تخبرنا أن
روسيا تحول تركيزها إلى تحقيق
هذا النصر في وقت مبكر ،
فربما تعرف ما إذا كانت روسيا تسيطر على
أجزاء من أوكرانيا.  سيتوقف عند هذا
الحد ، فلن يرغب في المزيد ،
إنه ذاهب
إلى الهدف ليس شيئًا مختلفًا ، لقد
نشر ما يريده
مرة أخرى في ديسمبر  يريد أوكرانيا أن
يسيطر على دول البلطيق ويريد السيطرة
على أوروبا الشرقية ، يريد أن يحطم
الناتو ويريد أن تخرج الولايات المتحدة ،
هذا لكل الكرات ، كل ما
يحاول فعله الآن هو المماطلة التي
يرغب في المماطلة الغربية.  تعزيز
أوكرانيا ، إنه يرغب في
نزع سلاحنا معنويًا معنويًا للاعتقاد
بأن هذا كل ما يريده ،
لكن الأمر ليس كذلك فهو يريد تعطيل
النظام الدولي ومعه
الصين في هذا الصين أه على
الهامش ربما ولكن تأصيل له
الصين.  بالنظر إلى تايوان ، تريد الصين أن
تؤكد نفسها ، لذا فإن الصين وروسيا قد
تعاونتا في هذه
أوكرانيا هي مجرد
ساحة المعركة الحالية ، ولكن
إذا هزم الأوكرانيون روسيا في ساحة المعركة هذه ، فإن
كل شيء يتغير ، لذا فإن
أفضل طريقة لحماية الناتو ، فإن أفضل طريقة
لحماية النظام الدولي هي
امنح أوكرانيا المساعدة التي تقول إنها
تحتاجها ودعهم يتعاملون مع روسيا في
ساحة المعركة هذه
أنت